differentiate sine of 3x okay now so far
when you've been doing channel you've
gotten familiar enough with it that you
skip out doing the full steps with like
let u equal this blah blah blah ah but
just because we're staying new family of
functions I'm gonna do it okay so let's
call this whole thing let's let y equal
sine 3x okay so let u equal 3x okay do
you remember how to chain rule
what well we wanted to say this is sine
okay so I differentiate the inside I
differentiate the outside here's the
inside right
so do you on DX is just three and he's
the outside
why do you now this is sine right so it
turns into cosine so it's going to be
cause all you okay not cos of X this
whole thing we've got a really exit okay
so therefore back to the original
definition table write dy DX is here's
my chain do you want under you do you on
the X okay so you can see it's three cos
Jude which is 3 cos 3x okay so now if
you like you can see how this works you
can once you feel comfortable with that
go straight from here all the way down
to here because you think to yourself
what's the inside function 3x
differentiate it put it out the front
and then differentiate the outside sign
turns into your son okay
all right let's ramp it up a little bit
how about the derivative all 10 that's
saying X
okay now what is this this is what is
this this is number one it's chain rule
because you've got ten of something and
then number two it's question rule okay
so when you've got questions like this
it's worth the effort and the time
rather than doing this all in your head
you say maybe off on the side or maybe
underneath you say the derivative ball
and then you just think about the inside
function and you forget about the tan
for a minute okay so what's the do
really evolve sorry thanks on X minus
one
let's do question what's together you
envy okay move on this red right so V X
minus one you - that's just one it's all
the other
- you which is just X again times me -
which is also 1 all over V squared this
turns out to be very conveniently just
minus one okay so now that I know why
was I doing this this is the derivative
of the inside ok so now I can say that
this is this disagree with the inside
and then you differentiate the outside
tan turns into SEC squared now I admit
this is just the beginning so you like
me I'm sure remembering all this the
best way to remember it is to use it ok
use it all there's a it's just like a
musical instrument for a sports skill as
you get familiar with it it'll become so
tare turns in a sec square Seck square
now by the way this is easy to forget
you right especially if you don't do the
full substitution ok it's not sex
squared X because the original function
had all of this mess inside there so the
mess comes with it ok so this is X 1 X 1
there's the driven
okay how about you can handle this how
about X cubed tan X this is product rule
isn't it okay so actually that's do it
let's dig cause because we just did -
okay so this is product rule so there's
U and V okay it's a product which is
just a bull so cos x u - which is 3x
bring the pat-downs squared careful with
your brackets by the way you don't get
that next mixed up with this 3 X with
plus U and V - which is - minus sign
watch out okay so causes causes a pain
just backwards okay so therefore this is
3x squared we tend to write the
polynomials the powers out the front
because then you don't get it confused
with the trig function - and if you
wanted you can factorize but that's
that's enough okay